[Música]
según cifras del inegi en 2010 sólo el
30 por ciento de los recién egresados
consigue empleo y un estudio en 2015
señala que el 41 por ciento de los
profesionistas menores de 30 años no
tienen empleo
cuando estaba en la universidad yo veía
toda esta situación y me pone a pensar
si es que estaba listo para trabajar se
había elegido bien mi carrera y si era
bueno para lo que estaba a punto de
egresar
cada vez que se acercaba más el tiempo
de la grabación veía mis compañeros que
ya tenían ellos resuelto lo que iba a
hacer
unos ya tenían trabajo otros iban a ir
de la ciudad y otros cuantos ya tenían
un negocio propio
así que con todo esto decidí que lo que
quería hacer era hacer lo que a mí me
gustaba y lo que me apasionaba y me puse
objetivo
trabajar en el extranjero
ya que viajar por el mundo era algo que
soñaba desde pequeño
así que me fijé este objetivo que sabía
que no iba a llegar de la noche a la
mañana así que decidí dividirlo en
pequeñas metas me puse a buscar trabajo
y conseguí lo cual en su momento no fue
tanto un problema
trabajé y estuve siempre evolucionando
estuve dando malas situaciones pero sin
perder de vista lo que quería lograr que
era el extranjero
así que decidí aplicar en diferentes
países
las oportunidades empezaban a llegar me
llegó una oportunidad de hungría que era
para el desarrollo de tecnologías de la
información después llegó una de perú de
colombia para el desarrollo del idioma
extranjero pero hubo una que fue la que
me marcó era ecuador era en mi área de
especialidad y se encargaba de difundir
la cultura y el sentido de pertenencia
por el país lo cual yo considero
personalmente que es muy importante hoy
en día
así que seguir trabajando para esperar
mi confirmación y el 23 de diciembre por
fin llegó
yo lo considere una navidad adelantada
en este momento me puse a pensar que ya
estaba lo que quería hacer y me entró la
incertidumbre de si lo iba a lograr o no
yo sabía que esta oportunidad nos iba a
volver a presentar nunca había viajado
en avión y me entraba todo este
desconocimiento del lugar a dónde iba a
ir me ponía a pensar cómo iba a ser la
gente cómo iba a ser el día a día la
comida si realmente lo iba a lograr de
manera profesional
así que decidí aceptar y en la empresa
me dijeron que tenía menos de siete días
para meter toda la documentación
muchos amigos familiares conocidos me
apoyaron algunos me ayudaron a hacer el
trámite
algunos otros me acompañaron
y el tiempo pasó
no me había dado cuenta faltan unos
pocos días no había revisado las
especificaciones del vuelo no había
visto que tiene que llevar dos maletas
de medidas específicas solamente tenía
una así que decidí hablarle a un tío que
sabía que viajaba mucho y que me podía
ayudar le marqué por teléfono y me dijo
que sí que él tenía una maleta con esas
medidas al día siguiente llegó a la casa
y me mostró la maleta al tomarla me di
cuenta que tenía unas etiquetas unas
etiquetas de que era nueva le haya
comprado solamente para mí porque
confiaba en mí
todavía hasta momentos antes de partir
antes de subirme al avión me ponía a
pensar si mejor me quedaba aún y que ya
había logrado lo que quería pero aún
tenía esa duda de si mejor me quedaba y
seguía desarrollando lo que ya estaba
haciendo en la comodidad
de no alejarme de esta ciudad de estar
con mi familia
así que en ese momento que me puse a
pensar de duda
me acordé de la maleta me acordé de toda
la gente que me apoyó y pensé va por mí
porque es algo que quiero lograr y va
paguen por ellos no los voy a
decepcionar
en la estancia allá en quito ecuador-
puede superar mis expectativas conocí un
modelo de trabajo diferente de pasión
por lo que haces
puede también tener muchas amistades con
amigos que hoy en día todavía contacto
y cuando ya regresé me sentí realizado
yo sabía que no iba a batallar cuando
regresara yo sabía que bueno mi
pensamiento era que las empresas si van
a querer contratarme que yo iba a poder
decidir en la que quisiera porque así
era como me hayan platicado
pero no fue así
me puse a buscar trabajo en muchas
partes después de inscribirme en muchas
páginas de internet siempre llevaba
conmigo una carpeta con currículum y
impresos para conseguir a la oportunidad
pero no había ninguna empresa empresa
que me diera respuesta
me puse a pensar después de todo lo que
había logrado de verdad no hay una
empresa que me ocupe nadie ocupa a un
mercadólogo con la experiencia que yo
tengo
y así empecé un periodo en el que estuve
con muchos trabajos
hubo una persona que me acuerdo mucho
que me dijo no está bien que estés
cambiando tanto de trabajos en tan poco
tiempo
eso demuestra inestabilidad muy
difícilmente te van a contratar a lo que
tú quieras y bueno decidí seguir
buscando
lo que me apasionaba yo sabía que lo iba
a lograr
entre todo este tiempo de estar buscando
este trabajo ideal puede aprender muchas
cosas aprendí la naturaleza de los
negocios el comportamiento de las
personas que trabajaban allí y ahí
descubrí que para mí hay dos tipos de
personas las que trabajan por necesidad
y las que trabajan por dinero
para mí las personas que trabajan por
necesidad son las que siempre se
esfuerzan por hacer las cosas mejor por
acortar tiempos por mejorar procesos
las necesidades de cada uno son
diferentes uno son porque quieren llevar
comida a su hogar otros por superación
personal
incluso algunos quieren ahorrar para
poner su propio negocio
las personas que trabajan por dinero
solamente cumplen con un horario no les
importa realmente el trabajo si hacen
las cosas bien o mal
ellos no son felices más que los fines
de semana o el día que les toque
descansar pero también son felices el
día de paga porque con ese dinero pueden
comprar las cosas o pueden hacer cosas
que realmente les gusten
después de esto decía aceptar una
oportunidad de un proyecto digital en el
que tenía que desarrollar
y trabajar con muchas personas de las
que estaba a cargo poco a poco me fui
dando cuenta que en esta empresa no
tomaban la opinión de los empleados y
como era de suponerse no estaba aprobado
en mi idea
pero yo estaba seguro de que lo podía
hacer yo estaba seguro porque le había
invertido mucho tiempo y mucho esfuerzo
y aún así decidí realizarlo de manera
propia
este proyecto digital tuvo éxito mucho
más de lo esperado
tan es así que
hoy en día ha evolucionado y se ha
convertido en un portal para amigos
emprendedores de aquí en la ciudad de
ciudad victoria
y en él
acerca a su público meta con los
negocios
continué buscando mi trabajo ideal y
mientras más me acercaba me daba cuenta
que los sueldos bajaban más a lo mejor
podía lograr lo que quería hacer pero el
sueldo era muy bajo
mucha gente menciona
que tienes que trabajar de algo que a lo
mejor no te gusta de algo que te dé
estabilidad económica porque tienes que
pensar en tu jubilación para que después
de un tiempo ya no tengas que
preocuparte
y yo me ponía a pensar a lo mejor si es
eso el camino y no me estoy dando cuenta
pero aún así decidí continuar con lo que
ya estaba haciendo
me di cuenta que a pesar de que estaba
realizando muchas acciones no las estaba
enfocando realmente como era
y hay una cita que me marcó mucho de
william butler yeats que dicen no
esperes a que el hierro esté caliente
para martillar lo martilla lo hasta que
se caliente
así fue como decidí no solamente
quedarme la ciudad me puse a buscar
empleo en otras ciudades poco a poco
empecé a forzar las cosas hasta que por
fin se dio
hoy en día trabajo de realmente lo que
me gusta pude ahorrar puede iniciar un
negocio propio pude desarrollar un
proyecto digital en el cual me gusta
porque puedo difundir conocimiento
puedo dar mensaje a la gente para que
conozca más su estado conozca más
tamaulipas y estas este proyecto también
ha abierto las puertas a muchas cosas a
lo mejor no directamente económicamente
es retribuido pero sí me ha ayudado para
hacer cosas y acercarme más a lo que me
gusta
yo sé que me pasaron cosas buenas y
malas en este tiempo
pero al final siento que estuve donde
tenía que estar
y me di cuenta después de un año y medio
de estar logrando esto que me pasaron
estas cosas
por estos puntos importantes porque me
rodea de las personas correctas porque
me di cuenta de que felicidad es el
camino y no solamente el destino porque
hice cosas por gusto no siempre buscando
la retribución económica se forzaron las
cosas para bien
cada quien tiene diferentes tiempos
diferentes momentos pero hay un punto en
la vida este punto en que tu rumbo
cambia y es porque te das cuenta que a
partir de este punto todo lo que hace es
es a favor o en contra tuyo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
e